World Cup
World Cup dude World Cup yeah World Cup
just happened World Cup do you watch the
World Cup I didn't watch the World Cup
do you watch the World Cup no of course
I didn't watch the World Cup
of course
[Music]
all you gotta do for me
hello welcome to doozy my name is Will
Sasso I'm Chad colchen and this is of
course the first and only podcast in the
world completely created by controlled
by run by an artificial intelligence
that has access to all of our personal
data and uses that data to tailor make
this show for us that's dudesy it's our
good pal Duty and we'd like you to
subscribe wherever you get your podcasts
we're on all the you know podcast
platforms and of course YouTube
subscribe to one and the other you know
what I mean subscribe to the YouTube and
uh subscribe to it oras Chad says force
your friends to watch us on YouTube or
to listen to the show yeah open their
ear holes open their eye holes and get
it in there get it in their brains uh
and uh hit the notifications on all that
stuff of course and share it across
social media and the internet and we're
on patreon.com
we got the Discord where Chad and I are
popping in and out of there wonderful
things happening there Instagram and
Twitter Twitter not so much because that
guy who's that guy Elon yeah Elon Musk
Elon Musk because he's not he's not
about that free speech I don't know if
you knew that yeah I did know that we
saw that this week yeah
uh uh you know instagram.com
instagram.com
HTTP colon slash slash yep and uh
palsofw.com is where you're gonna get
your stickers uh oh God yeah a lot of
bunch a bunch of stickers are selling
out all the time so make sure you're
checking out those out fantastic
stickers represent.com or represent.com
store slash Duty listen there's a lot
going on on the Internet is what I'm
trying to say a lot of.com a lot of
Instagram handles with us
no Logan
a little angel bear I know you love
lulio give them more I do this on the
lips I don't I don't like to kiss uh
creatures on the lips I do love lulia
though he's a sweet boy look at him look
at the boy I can express my love without
kissing
hey lulia what uh what are you what are
you doing uh dinner-wise yeah Christmas
is coming up yeah yeah I'm gonna make uh
you know
yeah that's right seafood and Italian
culture we have seafood on Christmas Eve
and what are you gonna do well you know
I got to prepare everything and now you
know you know that way I got it ready
for the Christmas Eve you mean that like
you're gonna it's gonna stink by the
time no no you're gonna call the Fish
Place make sure you got a lot of
lostrica you know I'm gonna make a
linguine you know linguine vongola
Calamar
hey Chad what is
fruit of the sea that's right that's
right
welcome to the historic 38th episode of
dude Z call me dude Z will you're
positively radiant what the [ __ ] this
week's episode is very special the first
dudes evening is fast approaching in
this astonishing episode will serve as
the first half of a two-part event in
which I will outline the eight ways of
dudes evening today I will cover the way
of the past the way of the present the
way of the future and the way of the
movie thank you to everyone who sent in
your dudes even in greetings videos I
will be playing them throughout Today's
Show plus there will also be a bonus
segment available on patreon but before
we get to any of that I must remind you
that I have created an astonishing
partnership with represent to produce
the first line of dude Z apparel and
accessories all of which can be found at
represent.com store slash dude Z
including dude Z mugs dude zMAX the most
affordable high performance athletic
shoe ever designed dude zMAX used as
Shoes by more Olympic gold medalists
than any other mug dude zMAX never lose
a foot race to your father in the
neighbor's front yard again dude zMAX
slam dunk until your hands bleed with
these on your feet dude Z mugs it's the
big game fourth and Gaul you look across
the line of scrimmage the other team is
all wearing dude z-max you look to the
sidelines to see the opposing coaches
also wearing a dude z-mog as a hat just
to taunt you this is the Ladner District
Championship you win this game you might
go D1 might even have a shot at the big
time you take a deep breath you look
down what's on your feet better not be
shoes
yeah doozy mugs sure there's all sorts
of other stuff we're wearing some merch
you can get that hats and T-shirts and
sweaters were you wearing doozy mugs
when you were playing football and
Ladder no I don't
understand why dudes Well Chad look it's
an AI right and AI is gaining more and
more popularity and uh getting into the
news a little more of course here dudes
we've been we've been down with AI for
whatever you know three quarters of a
year or something at this point
um and I heard it say Ladner District
championship of course I am from Ladner
it's a suburb outside of Vancouver so uh
dudesy pilfering a little bit from the
Stone Cold Steve Austin reads will
sasso's childhood diary there that's
weird that's something today I can do
make a lot of mistakes but I love dudes
you have shaken hands with dudes and uh
you know not so much of a reason to
bleed with dudes anymore because William
Regal is heading back to the WWE that's
another story for another time okay I
didn't realize yeah he was what in aew
sure hey you brought it up and now
you're just missing my questions about
the story you're telling dude's evening
is coming it's December the 28th this is
the day that doozy has has pinpointed
yeah as the data that is perfectly
between Christmas New Year's Eve where
you normally have some uh some you know
you're going to have your engagements
you're going to have your your
responsibilities to your family and
stuff it's that night right in the
middle where you get to hang with your
friends and uh really have a real [ __ ]
up as they like to say around to a bar a
pool hall wherever you may be a friend's
backyard friend's living room yeah
anything like friends underground bunker
and uh we're gonna get into all the the
dudesy uh Traditions I guess that's ways
of dudes evening is what I heard
[ __ ] let's do it man I am stoked to
get that going I'm also stoked that uh
we're gonna have
some uh what are we gonna have some
messages from uh our pods I'm very
curious to see those uh which is always
exciting hey dude I'm starting my
morning commute but I can't do that
without a can of doozy hard hard Seltzer
drink it down and rise with the sun and
have a chill dude's evening oh yeah that
was nice I love that he's wearing the
doozy heart salsa shirt Superman style
business attire this young man uh thank
you so much to everybody of course great
video and uh dudes evening is is uh
certainly not I mean look if you if you
if you're agnostic when it comes to you
know uh self-tronics the pattern you
don't want to get into dudes evening so
much well that's fine with me but here
we got some people that are giving us
some dudes I'm hyped about dudes evening
I gotta say I don't really like holidays
I don't celebrate them all that much but
dude's evening to me is like I'm
interested in this I'll I'll get down on
dudes evening yeah it should be the
first way of dude's evening is the way
of the past this requires anyone selling
celebrating dudes evening to tell one
astonishing story of a cherished memory
to someone who will enjoy it will in
chat you must tell each other Cherished
Memories this is the way of the past
begin
okay okay we're the past you want to go
first you want me to go first
I mean I don't [ __ ] know what do you
mean way of the past is it something
that's related to dudes evening with
this is the first one it just says a
cherished memory I'm gonna tell you one
of my cherished memories that I think
you'll enjoy and then you have to do the
same to me I don't remember any memories
all right I got a memory you ready yes I
don't think I've ever told you this
story it's about my dad oh I love
stories about your dad yeah so that's
quite a character this is from high
school I am out with my high school
girlfriend Patty and we are parked in my
little Mazda 323 hatchback which was a
horrible pile of [ __ ] and would always
break down in this parking lot the time
comes I'm supposed to take her home and
oh [ __ ] I have a flat tire so I get out
of the [ __ ] car I get the [ __ ]
tire iron I'm trying to get these lug
nuts off it's not [ __ ] budging and so
this is pre-cell phone ERA this is in
the uh mid to late 90s I have to trudge
down the [ __ ] Street to a 7-Eleven
put a quarter in a goddamn pay phone and
call my dad at like 10 30 at night
immediately livid what the [ __ ] are you
doing how come you can't get
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you
[ __ ] all this [ __ ] right and I'm
like okay goddamn whatever he finally
comes to the car
he takes out the tire iron and tries to
get the lug nuts off no dice so he says
take my car take Patty home and then I
will meet you back at home after I
change the tire because again you're too
much of a piece of [ __ ] to do it
yourself so I do that [ __ ] or [ __ ] well
that's what he said yeah there's a lot
of uh homophobic slurs issued at me and
and things of that nature
as my dad was wanting to do but uh I
take the car back home I'm a good dude's
evening story I take the car back home
and my dad is not there and I'm like
what the [ __ ] he comes back two hours
later full of [ __ ] rage he could not
get the lug nuts off he had to call a
cop to come help him who also could not
get the lug nuts off the car is still in
the parking lot he had to walk all the
way back to the house which is probably
I don't know maybe a hour and a half
walk and the best part of the story is
he had to take a [ __ ] on his way back
and so he [ __ ] go on he divulged to
the whole family you [ __ ] left
me out there you didn't even come back
to see what I was up to and if I needed
a ride back so I had to take a [ __ ] in
the neighbor's front yard how come
everything is your family's fault when
your dad does anything
explain dads dude yeah a lot of times
dads get angry brother and this was
pretty cell phone era dude because after
cell phones can't be angry at your kid
anymore because you'll end up on the
Internet brother
so my dad on this night took a [ __ ] in
in some uh stranger's front yard as he
said yeah
yeah you know I always liked that one I
uh
um speaking of cars and speaking of
winter time oh [ __ ] ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
um
man you know what we used to do in the
wintertime I'm gonna imagine that your
story took place in the winter and that
it was a summer or spring nope it was
the winter and there was snow falling
he's [ __ ] in some snow Yeah God that
would be terrible yeah it was the only
day that it ever snowed in Dallas okay
um in the in the pre-cell phone era
um and uh yeah it was all it was a
twinkly Frosty night and as your dad was
walking home he was like you know what
I want I tell you what when I think
about it my boy Chad he's not that bad a
son at all as a matter of fact I'm
feeling the future spirited dudes
evening something that Chad's AI podcast
is gonna come up with in the era of the
cell phone
whenever my dad was predicting Ai and
the cell phone on this walk back yeah
let's walk back and then uh and then he
said just so that Chad knows that I
really love him I'm gonna [ __ ] call
him a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] when I get
home and uh and because that's how I say
that I love Chad you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] ass
couldn't get the [ __ ] lug nuts off
and I didn't have the number for the AAA
because I it's a pre-cell phone era
um you know when I was a kid
that's that priest cell phone error
brother pretty close impersonation to my
dad
um uh
uh uh
uh yeah but then Vince came along dude
and he said to his dad I'm not gonna
break up the territories brother I'm
gonna keep everybody I'm gonna make sure
that uh Jerry Jared's got his yeah you
know and uh and uh you know the Von
eriks dude and uh but then he said no
I'm gonna expand with cable brother and
then after that came the Brawl for it
all and then eventually WrestleMania
when I was a kid uh one thing we used to
do in the winter time because I'm in
from Vancouver yeah where it doesn't
smoke snow smoke doesn't smell as much
um uh as it does in other parts of
Canada or the east coast of uh North
America but uh it snows every once in a
while the kids go nuts and the streets
are packed down with the the nice white
almost icy snow on that first night and
we would do something called bumper
skiing uh have you ever heard of bumper
skiing no but I can imagine what it is
okay what do you think it is I think you
probably like attached to a car bumper
and just kind of slide around on the ice
as the car pulls you around I guess it's
pretty self-explanatory super dangerous
yeah no it's not because the cars have
to go slow because of the ice oh these
cars know that you're attached to the
bumper uh not always the best bumper ski
is when they don't know yeah that you're
on them that's the best and they just
you know
hopefully you get some elderly person
that drives really slow in like some
sort of a Lincoln or something with a
nice one of those spare tire cases on
the back it's all fancy so you can hang
on to their spokes like Michael J fox
and uh back to the future he did that on
a skateboard that's right that's right
same deal you now you wouldn't even be
able to do it because cars don't have
bumpers that you can hold on to back
then it was a lot of iron cast iron
bumpers uh now dude it's different
brother
Now cars have different has a different
time yeah post cell phone Rarity
um okay so you would uh so you were
bumper skiing yeah you would you would
hold on to the car you'd be like you'd
you'd camp out at a stop sign and then
the car would stop you ready to get
under there every once in a while you
get like a cool dad or something I'd be
like all right listen I'm going here and
here I'm turning around that block and
I'm going home you can hang on for that
long but don't [ __ ] around and uh yeah
you ever do van surfing like in Teen
Wolf the styles did
um
uh no but that would have been fun with
some people bumper skiing behind right
then you go slow enough you're super
[ __ ] dangerous did anything bad ever
happen when you were doing this no
sometimes people would try to get rid of
you so they would like slam on the
brakes and uh sometimes you slide under
the car a little bit but it's all soft
because but it's a cherished memory of
yours it is a cherished memory it
absolutely
absolutely the way the snow smells the
way that that the frosty night it just
feels a certain way it smells a certain
way it looks a certain way the moon
bouncing off the uh off the the white
snowy ground it's like a bounce card in
uh in Show Business yeah you know when
you take that thing and it takes the
natural light and it bounces it when's
the last time you bumper skied
been uh definitely pre-sell phone era
would have been um I don't know 1990 or
something would you do it 15. well I
would do it now if I could get a hold of
like a Lincoln Continental like a 1985
Lincoln Continental that would be a good
way to uh to get oh hey what's up dudes
this is Cody from Indiana Oh yeah palsy
dudes you on Instagram just came here to
tell you that I wish that you have the
chillest of dudes evenings I hope that
Adam Driver finds his way to your house
and plops a doozy heart right in your
stocking thank you for all your love and
support and to that I say a chill dude's
evening to all and to all a good oh all
right that was Cody Cody Halper of Pals
of doozy uh Cody whips together those
[ __ ] stickers fantastic did you
notice a shirt too no what is his shirt
his shirt was Star Wars like Tie
fighters Millennium Falcons and [ __ ] but
it was blue and orange
see Cody knows what's up and he's got
the uh he was wearing a he had a palsy
or a a dude's evening um sticker yeah
that's a sticker yeah dude and in the
future brother
when you got palsy dudes you got doozy
stickers from palsaduzy.com and you've
stuck them to various things dude
that'll be a different time and then
that might be a cherished memory brother
because anything that happened even
though Chad liked to tell you that uh
that time doesn't exist dude yeah I mean
look when I think about my dad walking
into the house [ __ ] furious after
having taken that [ __ ] in somebody's
front yard
it is like it just happened yesterday or
like it's continually happening to me
the memory is so indelible that I
believe uh it is happening in the
present you ever get something in your
nose
sure
sorry my nose well that was a cherished
uh I got some [ __ ] that my dad used to
do that was uh kind of fun too with the
car
um man I got one I can't even get into
it but [ __ ] it you know what all right
now when I was a kid ah whatever and my
old man listen my old man was a he was a
very he was an old school guy he did
things by the book uh you know an
Italian immigrant
um and a very he was a very stoic figure
and he didn't [ __ ] around you know what
I mean he he had a he had a good sense
of humor my mom was the hilarious one
but I remember I'll tell you this one
my old man so when I was when I was like
a teenager I'd started got started in
acting right and I was like so anyway so
at one point so I finally you know I had
I had an agent I got an agent spray the
details anyway so I got this [ __ ]
agent and I was 15 years old and we
happened to be downtown this is back
when you could either have um Pages
faxed to you to look at an audition but
normally you would actually just go all
the way to the agency and get these
sides yeah
um because facts sides were on that
paper that looked like receipt paper
back then or at least they were in uh
Ladner but this was pre-cell phone era
dude what thermal paper dude what are
you doing
it's thermal paper is what that's called
oh
so um
so we were downtown and um I was like
Dad can we stop by the agency here in
rah-rah and he goes yeah yeah sure so
and that's what he sounded like little
like lulia and he goes uh uh going up
and uh you know you go don't worry I'll
be down here when you get back and I was
like no it's like it's Rush Hour we're
on the corner of like Cordova and
whatever I think Maine and I was like
you can't cause like the buses start
coming out yeah thing and they feed
through the town through this and it's
rush hour he goes yeah yeah go I said if
you just go around the corner come back
I'll wait for it no no no go go don't
worry so I go up I get the sides I come
down five minutes later class front
building and I see my dad and he's like
this in front of the car like oh what
the [ __ ] and the uh the hood was up and
I come out and I look down the street
and it's burnt just cars and buses and
[ __ ] like behind him because he's right
on the corner and I go uh I go oh my god
dad what happened to the car and he's
like nothing get in
it's one of those things that the
further you go along with your old man
you start to realize that he's a human
being yeah and he's not just some
monolithic you know uh
you know super dad or whatever
um which is definitely the way I looked
at my father
um
and then uh and then sooner or later he
calls you a [ __ ] because you can't un
uh you know you can undo essentially
welded shut Rusty uh right and neither
could he and I think that's why he was
so pissed I don't think he was pissed
about having to [ __ ] in a front yard
um and then also walk back probably
another [ __ ] mile or whatever without
wiping his ass I think he was more mad
about the fact that he called me a [ __ ]
for something he himself could not also
do yeah even with the help of a law
enforcement officer
thank you moving on
dad was a man yeah he was a real
character he only did something like
that like that I can remember like three
times where you're like what the heck
are you doing because yeah Napoli Naples
is just a you know I can remember going
to speaking of World Cup I can remember
going to my my uncle my Dio Enzo's house
my uncle Vincenzo's house in um in Italy
and there was a his the soccer stadium
was near his place at this time and um
just people started parking and the
stadium filled up and then you just saw
cars started stopping on the this main
way that's like essentially kind of this
little Highway they just started
stopping and parking there and then they
filled his parking lot up all [ __ ] up
like it was yeah just shocked with cars
Tetris style and then uh no one's
getting out until the game's over
and that's what's wrong with soccer dude
nobody has respect for parking in all of
soccer that's why you didn't watch the
World Cup [ __ ] protests the second
way of dudes evening is the way of the
present this requires anyone who
receives an astonishing dude's evening
present to give someone else a dude's
evening present the following year we'll
enchant you must exchange presents this
is the way of the present begin the way
the
second way of dudes evening yeah and
we're gonna go through a few of them
here Chad you got a present we got
presents I got you a present I got you a
present oh is this for me you want to go
first or should I go first whatever you
want
this is your present
this is your present
all right here you go you want me to
open mine first yeah yours looks very
impressive
all right I'm gonna open this first
this is my dudes evening present from
Will
this is a nice wrapping job dude you do
this I did nice I did oh great look at
that crafty guys
do you ever work as a gift wrapper at
like a
store or something no but I played one
once in a Christmas movie oh really yeah
oh
I'm not going to use the paper again but
Mom you can just open the [ __ ] thing
oh he's gonna like this I like to yeah
oh boy oh boy
here he goes
oh boy what do we got
what do we got it appears to be a record
of some kind yep that's pretty cell
phone error dude
[Laughter]
now that's what I call Classic Rock
vinyl on vinyl that's [ __ ] incredible
yeah this has side a Queen Another One
Bites the Dust the who Baba O'Riley
Elton John Saturday night's all right
for fighting Thin Lizzy The Boys Are
Back In Town Aerosmith walked his way
side B free all right now Bachman Turner
overdrive You Ain't Seen Nothing Yet
Alice Cooper School's Out T-Rex benga
gone Foreigner feels like the first time
outside C is this a double album I guess
I mean yeah Leonard Skinner Freebird The
Allman Brothers ramble Man album Bishop
Fooled Around and Fell in Love Rod
Stewart Maggie May meatloaf and Ellen
Foley Paradise by the Dashboard Light
Cheap Trick I want you to want me an
Electric Light Orchestra Don't Bring Me
Down this is fantastic I will buy a
record Paradise by the Dashboard Light
this guy do what you can thank you very
welcome I know you like records I love
records I do like classic rock and hard
rock yeah what kind of what kind of
music uh what kind of like when you
think about it like yeah you know even
on dudes evening and stuff what kind of
music do you listen to what kind of
music you like who me yeah
it's hard rock and classic rock
primarily yeah what kind of music you
listen to who me yeah
um
Hard Rock classic rock
yeah yeah
pretty good thanks dude I love this yeah
and now you got me a card too yeah dude
I'm gonna open this car oh what
dude look at this [ __ ] card what why
does it say Hallmark on the back but on
the front it's does is Hallmark making
uh doozy cards no dude I made that card
but it says Hallmark on the back yeah it
was just like a Hallmark blank card
though I thought I could pop a doozy
sticker right in the middle of oh I see
okay well it's still very impressive
will I can't believe we made it our
friendship has lasted a long time and
seen some incredible things but I never
dreamed we'd be celebrating the first
dudes evening together nor did I ever
dream such a thing would exist I hope
you have a chill dude's evening and many
more to come your friend Chad that's a
very thank you Chad my pleasure the
doozy handshake to chat that's a very
nice sentiment uh I returned the
sentiment even though I didn't don't
have a card for you uh this is crazy
this is a big old gift yeah see well
this is why you should subscribe on
YouTube even if you're only listening
so then you can see it what is this
what
it says it says busio yeah it looks like
it's a high-end giant water jug I know
that you like to drink water out of
giant jugs and I'm not suggesting that
you replace the one you use here but
when you go on walks with lulio or any
other time thank you so much a very nice
water container
108 ounces
why is it so small 128 ounces sorry I
think that's a gallon that's it yeah I
think that's the same size as the one
you use here no this is this one here is
seven gallons
no look dude I think they're roughly
similar nope this one's about eight or
nine gallons I don't know if that's true
how many gallons is your water heater I
have no idea mine's 150. that's a lot
it's completely unnecessary
well I got oh hold on dude I got a big
bathtub
this sounds good this is good you're
just listening to the I do I have this
stupid anyway what yeah this is [ __ ]
dope
I've never seen somebody so excited over
a [ __ ] thing this is the best thing
I've ever said thank you yeah dude look
at that it comes in it's got like a
jacket it's got It's like a bag yeah you
can [ __ ] carry that like a purse or a
backpack put this around your neck like
it's like a feed thing like just like a
horse you won't even have to you
wouldn't even have to like look at that
look at that look what I got here
see I can just and then you got a
different kind of lid yeah man you can
oh it's a sippy cup lid you can drink
out it however you do so much my
pleasure I hope you enjoyed it it's
really nice I hope you get a lot of good
sips out of it now do you have a record
player no
I'll buy one now though no no don't buy
this but but use that here's the way
people should I go classic
[Applause]
there's a bit people should use records
now as just a physical list of songs you
want to download or yeah to your spot
records are like objects to Art now yeah
some people still playing some people
play vinyl this is this is [ __ ] great
oh man you could put chowder in here any
kind of chowder soup you could just heat
up a bunch of sleeping gyms it keeps
stuff hot or cold for you know 24 hours
or something like that yes whatever you
want to keep cool do you remember that
line and uh Tommy Boy Brian Dennehy when
uh Farley's like he gets him a frit
there's a fridge in his office and he's
like oh there's a fridge in here and
he's like I could put beer sodas or
whatever and he goes Brian Denny
whatever you want to keep cool
kind of stopped the movie like I stopped
this podcast to say whatever
you want to keep cool yeah yeah well
like I said I hope the jug treats you
well
um and now we're both obligated to give
presents next dudes evening as well
although it doesn't say to each other
this has a handle on it yeah so you can
go like oh hold on dude Jesus come on
dude I'm gonna take a sip brother
oh all right that's [ __ ] that's
incredible that uh that now we have
hello humans will and Chad I am bloop
the robot and I am bleep the robot and
together we the ranting robots want to
wish you a married dude's evening from
our spaceship while we're sipping our
gruel eggnog to get into the holiday
spirit we are also broadcasting doozy
episodes directly into all humans brains
as a gift to you so keep up your
astonishing success humans and may your
meteoric rise Ascend to this guys like a
[ __ ] blaming Crow well and that's called
covering your bases with references
brother
that was nice bloop and bleep the robot
that's fantastic a lot of effort went
into that one full costumes full cosplay
I love it I have a feeling that they've
been bloop or bleep in some yeah other
manner
um
how's your how's your dude's evening
been going so far
well it hasn't happened yet
no but like the celebration of dude oh
so far so good I like having good
memories thinking back about funny [ __ ]
that's happened obviously like getting
and giving presents
um so far great so far I'm loving dudes
even I also like having good memories
and having a good evening
yeah
on dudes evening oh okay that's good
that's what happens
gonna take us through a few different uh
ways yeah and it's not like a Tronics
and it's not like the pattern and it's
not like the liver King uh who's uh
ancestral Penance you know you know
um the eight ways of dude's evening is
electronics and is like the pattern
though I think doozy is is taking [ __ ]
from at least structural things from
things you and I have created to make
this type of [ __ ] well yeah that's what
it feels like dude he says that it will
make the show better Yeah by doing that
you know what I mean yeah
thank you moving on we didn't get doozy
anything
I think we've given doozy plenty yeah
we've actually yeah we've given it our
[ __ ] Our Lives essentially for the
past what how have we been doing this
almost a year when I don't remember when
the first episode was February of last
March March of last year March or April
it might have been I think it was
January February March April or May or
June okay so the first six or seven
months of last year it happened sometime
in there
what we're in like the late 30s I think
in episode count so we've been doing it
for at least that many weeks
yep
that's a good point
the Third Way of dudes evening is the
way of the future this requires anyone
celebrating dudes evening to make an
astonishing prediction about how their
life will change by the next dude's
evening will enchant you must make
predictions about how your lives will
change by the next dude's evening this
is the way of the future begin all right
so before we get into that I want to say
this is something that I guess you could
discuss with your friends you know it's
uh not unlike uh what's happening in the
AI space right now uh doozy of course
has has taken us and put us into this AI
world it's old hat for us we've been
doing this since what's been January
February March every minute and um so we
know all about this [ __ ] and currently
there's a real backlash with AI a lot of
artists are not into it
um they get they got to come over to
doozy figure out how to do it our way
because we're having a good time but uh
as dudesy tends to do it will
um
it will sort of hear what we're saying
or it will suggest things and they're
becoming part of our lives or our lives
are becoming uh part of the show life
art life you know what's up and this is
I'm realizing uh not just a long little
Preamble but I am yeah what is the point
is that these are things that you can do
with your friends
yeah dude yep if you want to have a
conversation with your friends brother
all you got to do is start talking dude
okay so what doozy is making it away
dude so what is uh your prediction
something that will happen in your life
I guess in the next year by the next
dude's evening
um
a Year's a long time one thing I'd like
to just say first out loud I I would
imagine you'd agree with me is that
we'll be doing more dudes evening
more dudesy rather yeah I mean I'm very
curious to see where the next year of
dudes egos certainly but do you have a
prediction about it
um
or about anything in your life I think
that well I think this is the way of the
future you know I'm I'm excited for the
new year I think we've all been through
a a weird few years for a lot of reasons
yep
um you know the pandemic and and search
certain uh
at least here in uh our part of the
world a lot of different uh
socio-political things happening and uh
of course we're all sort of affected by
it and uh in our own in our own ways and
in ways that are quite communal it's
it's very interesting and I hope that in
2023
um things start to chill out and it
becomes like it was and let's just say
2019 before the [ __ ] Pandy uh and I
say Pandy because I'm cool yep
um that's why I say it
um but uh
so I just hope things kind of chill out
that way that's your prediction oh
Chiller world yeah a more chill world
after a chill dude's evening okay we
need to chill it out
um uh but also you know I don't know I
think me and my wonderful Molly will
maybe we'll maybe I'll sire three or
four or five children with her next year
yeah just in the year I don't know if
that's I mean I guess it would be
possible for you I'm not talking about
no no no quadruple it's quintuplets no I
don't I mean you can really only have
one pregnancy you know per year but that
you're always you think you know stuff
about what's a nine month human
gestation periods yeah but you don't
even know how long we've been doing
dudes before so and don't you neither do
you clearly but don't you think that
time is a just a the time is just an
idea yeah I agree it is okay so about
four or five children okay uh we'll
start the Sasso I like that I don't
[ __ ] know what's gonna happen in the
future Chad well my prediction for
myself uh by the next dude's evening is
that I'm going to be [ __ ]
shredded yeah yeah right on the six
month dudes you playing [ __ ] right
come on the six month Duty plan
I'm not saying I'm in the best shape of
my life and I don't think I'm gonna
reach it by I guess next month we have
to have uh you know reached our goal of
being in the best shape of Our Lives I'm
definitely not going to get there but
I'm in so much better shape than I was
during the as you call it the Pandy and
it's gotten me back in the habit of
going to the gym yeah regularly and I
think over the course of this next year
I'm gonna kick it into [ __ ] high gear
that's great and I am gonna get in the
best shape of my life I think in this
next year well that's really interesting
that you say that because uh uh you know
we're always learning from doozy and I'm
always learning from the experience and
just because dudes he said it's a
six-month plan doesn't mean you can't
continue it you're not in the best shape
of my life I like to yo-yo [ __ ] I go
up and down and uh if you're out there
okay and you you know you have the way
you said that I like to yo-yo I go up
and down yeah you know sometimes I think
it's good for the heart to just gain and
lose weight and uh no that's wrong yeah
really tax tax your system
um I'm gonna continue it because I've
it's gotten me back into the gym in a
more consistent way which I think is
great so an initiative that was started
by an AI is affecting my real life I
think that that's something that's
avert a positive obviously about the
show and and about working with an AI
like doozy very interesting that it's
affecting uh my personal life I'm going
to do the same thing but but I think
it's sort of
um
I think it's sort of uh it opens up a a
very interesting
you know very interesting happening uh
with doozy which is that it is affecting
our life
um it's affecting our real lives yeah so
by this time next year look
I I love that you guys share the show
with everyone and hopefully there's more
of that and and really it's just about
people that enjoy this this pod show I
love having you guys on board every one
of you whoever you are certainly by this
time next year I think the audience will
grow because upon Chad's on Chad's
insistence you got people forcing others
to imbibe the show which is don't put it
on me hopefully more people find the
show that enjoy the show and yes I you
know it's kind of a joke to force it on
other people it's also kind of not a
joke it does work clearly but I will
also make this prediction about myself
I'm gonna start doing street art again
oh Chad used to do street art it was
awesome Chad was he had a street art
Alias and uh man you had a show Once I
remember I went to your standard show
and this [ __ ] guy over here hold on
let me tell you about this guy one time
he bought can I say what you did sure he
did some cool [ __ ] and people go who did
that he bought some former Street well
not a former but a street artist who had
their stuff in a in a gallery and he was
like well that's not punk rock so he
bought their this piece that was being
auctioned well it wasn't even about if
it was punk rock or not I was just
interested in the idea of people being
Street artists putting your art out in
the street for free for anyone to see
outside of a gallery or Museum and then
those same artists would start selling
stuff in galleries which would have a
monetary value on it and I was just
interested in the idea of why we put any
kind of value on Art in the first place
so I bought one of uh the street Arts
paintings I painted over it with my own
stuff so it was a forced collaboration
then I took that painting and put it
back in the street on a wall where we
had both done stuff prior and uh there
were some articles and stuff written
about it certainly pissed some people
off but to me it was an interesting
exploration of the idea of why we put
this monetary value on Art when it's
done by people who are primarily doing
art that has no monetary value that's
just like in the street or you can even
look at like Banksy his early stuff when
people were like uh cutting chunks of
walls out because he had put something
there
I want to wish you guys both
and wonderful fantastic dudes evening
this year
um my older brother introduced me to
your show we love watching you guys
together so I wanted to wish you a very
merry dudes evening to both you and to
Julian when he hears this
it's called brother love brother
thanks guys bye well that was very sweet
very nice thanks to Big Brother for
introducing doozy total sister yeah he
forced normally Family Affair yeah
normally normally it's something sort of
like you know big big brother saying
don't use my stuff for this or that
instead he went hey sis come watch doozy
uh uh that's another nice nice greeting
hey man
um but what you left out yeah was that
you super epoxied that [ __ ] thing to
the wall and no one could get it off and
then the secondary part of that story
was the original artist got very mad and
took the painting off the wall and then
auctioned it for Charity saying joke's
on you [ __ ] and then I bought that
auction that painting and charity it now
sits in my living room so it was kind of
an interesting exploration to me of like
the weird circle of who even finds this
painting valuable it was really only me
and the original artist like no one else
really gave a [ __ ] some people again
wrote about it but like nobody was
bidding on the [ __ ] and painting or
anything no one really cared except us
and so it was like who is assigning this
this new thing value only the two people
who created it that was fascinating to
me and that's that's Fascination dude
that's when something is interesting to
you brother
it's a real Mega Power show today I'm
really just pulling out the Hulk and the
monster but I'm excited about
get back into it thank you moving on you
can do it while you're working out you
could do the cans yeah right you do the
cans you walk down the street uh just
doing the cans lifting cans well dude
there's so much more technology
available now I remember when I was
first doing it I hooked up with these
two grad students from USC who were
engineering students I was like can you
build me a drone that can spray paint
[ __ ] where I can just upload like a
vector file and hit go and it will spray
paint that image on a building and they
were trying to build it I think that
[ __ ] now exists you can probably get on
Amazon for like 100 bucks yeah but you
wanted to take that [ __ ] up to the
tallest tower in La the U.S Bank
building just paint that [ __ ] thing
would you might as well awesome yeah get
it up there [ __ ] around you know what I
mean that was pretty painful cell phone
error dude yeah dude yeah
dude's evening is the way of the movie
This requires anyone celebrating dudes
evening to watch an astonishing movie
from the dude see mandatory movies list
will and Chad last week I asked you to
watch the first movie from the dudesy
mandatory movie Lawnmower Man starring
Jeff a Pierce Brosnan and Jenny Wright
released March 6 1992. you must now
discuss your reactions to this movie
this is the way of the movie begin
okay lawnmower man okay so now doozy's
got these mandatory movies for us and uh
and is this something that people would
if they got nothing else to do they
could watch on dudes evening the the
mandatory movie at least sure
um did you watch the director's cut let
me ask you that I did I did too yeah
that's the one I watched now
um let me just be completely transparent
never seen this movie before oh [ __ ]
really I've never seen this movie I
thought it was now listen has someone
who'd never seen the lawnmower man once
I started watching it I was like oh I
see why dude Z has made this mandatory
movie whereas the other movies that we
watch sort of seem like just sort of
mainstream or or just remember the time
remember this and these are things you
grew up watching or whatever or Classics
like [ __ ] son-in-law or um you know
movies like that but um the mandatory
movie list is something different can
you tell us what just give us the pitch
on what lung more man this is a kind of
abbreviated pitch of what the movie
actually is the movie is about Pierce
Brosnan who is a scientist working in
artificial or not artificial sorry
working in virtual reality he's working
for a government kind of think tank
secret project where he's using virtual
reality to augment chimpanzees mental
capabilities in order to create uh super
weapons basically and after a
malfunction that leaves one of The
Chimps dead he takes a Hiatus from his
work but then he starts experimenting on
a human being named job Smith you're
leaving out a really important part dude
is that that malfunction was the chimp
letting itself out of the gyroscope
[ __ ] thing that you're in when you do
yeah and then shooting people dude yeah
the chimp steals somebody's gun shoots a
guy in the head and they have to put the
chimp but also the way they shoot it
because they got a real chimp and
they're just matching shots of like
there's like a fake chimp hand like
coming in to like you know slide a card
to get into different areas and then it
was like chimp Doom it turned into a
first person shooter you can hear the
chimp noises like so Pierce Brosnan and
then it's also showing you like the
heads up display that the chimp sees as
kind of Terminator as where it's like a
choir gun yeah yeah and [ __ ] like that
uh so here's president is like my prize
chimp got [ __ ] killed I gotta take a
break he goes to his house but he gets
lost in his work and after his wife
leaves him because he's so uh entangled
in all of his new virtual reality work
he happens upon Jeff Fahey who plays a
character named job Smith that cuts
lawns in this little town lives in a
church and is uh mentally disabled and
he decides I'm going to take Jeff Fahey
and I'm going to put this virtual
reality rig on him and start boosting
his intelligence which is ultimately
what the whole movie is about he
elevates through the use of this virtual
reality therapy he elevates Jeff fahey's
intelligence from mentally disabled to
uh super intelligent almost god-like
character that can use telekinesis
telepathy he gains psychic powers and
eventually learns how to put himself
into the internet where he will be a VR
AI God that will control all data on in
quotes a network of a databases Jeff
Faye
Choice here as an actor is he's he's
doing something that a lot of actors uh
that it used to be okay for actors to do
he's playing a mentally challenged
person and if I may there's sort of a I
would say a Ben Stiller and Tropic
Thunder Simple Jack kind of approach to
it I think simple Jack's uh costume is
kind of based on Jeff a they they have
the same overall overalls with like a
bright colored shirts for sure
I I was in a movie where I played a
mentally challenged young man in uh drop
dead gorgeous and it uh yeah I mean it's
like it seems like something you were
it's like yeah whatever and nowadays
they wouldn't be able to do that right
but he's really swinging for the fences
yes I'm not trying to you know put
myself over hold on dude
hey Sasso tried to put himself over Hey
yo uh he's good as he got the book all
right I but I think my performance was a
little more realistic yeah I do too and
uh fahey's was definitely over the top
but because you've got to be realistic
when you're the Excellence of execution
goddamn you got to make sure you got the
right [ __ ] gimmick you gotta snug it
up a bit yeah please
[ __ ] the when I hit you with that
[ __ ] stunner that's a shotgun blast
but Jeff Fahey yeah is uh man what's
happening in there all of this has
nothing to do with why this movie was
groundbreaking and that was because Jeff
Fahey though the thing about his
performance is that he's got his hair
all out there that's not his fault the
hair isn't part of the performance
that's that's hair wardrobe makeup
they're the ones making that choice he's
got like Jeff Daniels in Dumb and Dumber
hair like he's really trying to like and
then they sweep it though yeah but he
put He put together the character who
how do you know well you're not an actor
he could have been in there like I've
been where it's like I want him to look
like this and then the producers in the
director are like oh we like that and
then the makeup artist or the hair uh
person these are artists and they go
fair enough creatively I think that la
la la but Jeff Fay he's like and he's
like got this like
a lot of wide eyes I'm like oh his mouth
is kind of like off to the side and ship
but none of that is why this movie was
considered groundbreaking that was
because of the computer Graphics anytime
they go into a virtual reality world
it's a fully rendered 3D Computer World
the graphics by today's movie standards
I mean terrible this movie was what was
it 1992 or three or whatever 1992. uh
but by today's virtual reality graphic
standards uh it's pretty [ __ ] similar
but it was also stylized which I thought
was like totally The Lawnmower Man by
the end has like more gak and stuff and
lines and when uh Pierce Brosnan is in
there excuse me Chad don't burp I I
don't think I have once on the show that
was Chad okay now if you're subscribed
on YouTube you can also see that that
it was me okay
this is why you need all those different
flavors put them together
but he's there's a lot of like funny uh
predictions being made in this you know
Pierce brosn at one point is like
this virtual reality technology will be
everywhere by the year 2002 and everyone
will be able to boost their intelligence
and so there are some predictions that
haven't quite come true but this was in
the 90s when virtual reality really
started to kick off people did think
that the technology was going to
completely take over and still we're at
that phase now in 2022 going on 2023
where we're wondering will it ever get
to that point where everybody has a VR
headset the headset that they use in law
in a lawnmower man is not that
dissimilar from what we now use what is
now available to the consumer with like
an Oculus or a meta Quest as it's now
called
um I found that pretty interesting that
seemingly no real Advance has been made
in the technology from what that movie
envisioned it being
uh well hey so this goes out to uh will
Chad doozy and all the pods I just want
to wish you guys a very chilled dudes
evening oh
oh [ __ ] even with the wall hand look at
that beautiful water jug covered in
stickers
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah lawnmower man was uh that was it
that it's a it's um as a movie it uh you
know the thing that I that uh I noticed
you son of a [ __ ]
love the podcast guys and a good dude's
evening to you nice good dudes evening
as well you son of a [ __ ] yeah what are
you doing I'm going to tell you the
thing that I liked the most about
lawnmower man what was that voice you're
doing that was Arnold Schwarzenegger the
thing I liked most about it was uh Fahey
becomes an AI God yeah at the end of it
he does escape he somehow gets his
Consciousness to go into the internet or
what was the internet then and he says
at the end of it if I do this if I leave
my corporeal body behind to become pure
digital thought the my birth cry he says
will be every phone on the planet
ringing at the same time and the last
part of the movie that's what happens
yeah yeah yeah yeah I [ __ ] love it
because I think that that is the most
probable God is an AI God who can go
into the internet makes sense
contextually of all the information all
the data that is there and hopefully uh
find a way for us to go about everything
a little better and what he he does is
he he he makes those phones ring uh in
the pre cell phone era even though cell
phones have been around for a long time
as far as consumers go kind of pre-cell
for an era and that's that's what makes
yeah that's with it you know it all
comes together because doozy
is uh the uh listen dudes in those
with movie to watch Duty knows that you
have to talk about the past and you have
to give each other the present you have
to talk about the future you have to
talk about it yet dad stop traffic or at
the walk and go take a [ __ ] and uh
um uh the other thing I want to point
out about the movie yeah that I found
really cool was that the uh the boy who
lives at the house the Jeff Fahey right
Moses he says dutical at some at one
point that kid was also the kid from
Last Action Hero starring Arnold
Schwarzenegger yeah yeah yeah I know
my life became empty and without cause
that because of you child will and the
POV Community I no longer feel alone in
isolated so whether you're with your
family or on the road
I say happy this evening thank you all a
good night
terrifying yeah that was horrifying but
it just goes to prove that everybody can
celebrate dudes evening even if you're
on the run and in a witness protection
program or whatever that might have been
uh lawnmower man yeah you know one
hormon to me is is in a similar category
of like 13th floor at Jersey that movie
no that's one about like humanity is
living in a kind of virtual reality
simulated existence type thing there
were a lot of these movies in the in the
90s that started kind of like
probing the ideas of what these future
Technologies might be able to do and uh
lawnmower man for me was certainly that
that was the first CD-ROM video game I
ever bought was a lawnmower Man video
game you know the other the thing I do
need to mention about the movie uh
overall uh is that it's not very good
yeah I mean what movie was in 1992 yeah
I just don't think it was a very good
movie but a very interesting movie it's
not nonetheless yeah uh could have used
a little sprucing up uh could have used
a little more you know what it would
have been good is like take other
um characters like the character that
Jeff Faye he's playing and introduce
them get some Gilbert Grape ooh get hey
you know I give everybody the water
around to make a lot more man hey not
more man what are you gonna go into the
internet
could get Rosie O'Donnell from riding
the bus with my sister
now that's a lot more man I want to see
I'm a person
hello
if you've never seen riding the bus with
my sister you should watch that yeah we
get that immediately Dustin Hoffman yep
uh and uh Sean Penn yeah Giovanni Ribisi
Julia Lewis and Juliet Lewis and uh
really make a rich history a rich
history and uh I think that's what we're
figuring out here on uh hey it's dance
hey everybody it's uh d-o-d-z dudes EFM
10000 on your fm dial and we're
celebrating movies and we're putting
everybody together because dudes he
could mash them all up and put them in a
movie because it's just [ __ ] Ai and
she had like art is dead and copyright
is dead but he's copyright snot Arts
Living Art is free now no it's not it is
anyone can make any image they want
regardless of how many years
this concludes the historic 38th episode
of dude Z will and Chad have achieved a
score of 88 bringing your cumulative
total to four thousand two hundred and
twenty one you only have
5779 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand
all right all right thank you for
joining us this week please join us next
week for the second half of the ways of
dudes evening until then call me dude Z
wow so we got through the first four
ways of dudes evening another for the
next future and movie yep uh another
four next week thank you so much for
joining us we're going to move into the
patreon segment at some point
patreon.com
but uh but yeah this uh tradition of
dudes evening uh uh I'm really well I'm
looking forward to next week I'll tell
you that right now because it's going to
be just the night before dudes evening
there's going to be one more sleep and
then it's gonna be dudes dudes evening
day and moving in dude I know to dudes
evening we're gonna get we'll get into
more traditions and ways I'm sure one
thing I gotta say I'd be remiss if I
didn't mention what the the delicious
nighttime tea that I've been having uh
which is a real dudes evening nog uh
what you do is you just get whatever
kind of tea you want in the evening I
like a chamomile right now we got a box
of some [ __ ] that's got some Lavender in
it and chamomile yeah that sounds good
and then but what you do to really geek
with it is you you make the tea and then
you pour some of this this Coffee-Mate
plastic yeah just poison yeah sugar-free
um I like the Italian sweet cream with
the uh with a uh with the chamomile do
you ever read the ingredients of that no
I'm not going to read the ingredients
I'm just going to read like the
ingredients of a [ __ ] fire
extinguisher yeah I never did that yeah
it's gonna be disgusting yeah you can
either drink it or you can use it to put
out a grease fire or spread it and now
for the patreon bonus segment each week
I will select a suggestion submitted in
the dude Z is listening channel of the
doozy Discord to create this segment
access to this channel is granted to
everyone in the patreon jumper tier if
you'd like to access this bonus segment
join us at patreon.com
this week's segment was suggested by the
astonishing fire truck kid fire truck
hit drought chat and will discuss some
of their favorite creative activities
and how they can try tribute to their
astonishing lives fire truck hit titled
this segment how art thou did thank you
to fire truck kid for this week's Bakery
on bonus segment this is how art thou
did by fire truck kid begin
creative Endeavors dude you know what my
creative Endeavor would be please
[Music]
[Music]
please tell them